let's return to kenya now where the
supreme court has been ruling on the
result of the presidential election the
disputed presidential election let's
bring in malcolm webb in nairobi i
believe we have a decision now from the
supreme court on uh the victory of
william rooter
kenya's chief justice martha comey has
announced here at the court
that the seven supreme court judges
unanimously agreed
to uphold the announcement of the
electoral commission
of william ruto as the president elect
of kenya it went through
she went through the
petitions submitted by his main opponent
ryla rodinger and other rights groups
and rejected all of the complaints
citing that there was inadequate
evidence and other reasons
and that the court didn't have a reason
to nullify the election as it had done
five years ago uh when riley redinger
filed a petition uh and the same supreme
court uh overturned the election and
ordered a rebound on this occasion it
has not we're waiting to find out uh
what the reaction will be
of supporters of ruto and ryla
but both of the leaders have said that
they will respect the judgment uh that
is coming here from the court just to
recap for our viewers who are just
joining us now on this newshour malcolm
kenya's supreme court has upheld the
august 9th election uh victory of
william ruto rejecting
all the challenges that had been made by
his opponent
veteran politician raila odinga
this decision just happening in the last
few minutes in the kenyan capital
nairobi so is this now it as far as this
election is concerned william roto is
officially the next president of kenya
we'd expect according to the
constitution william ruto to be sworn in
as president sometime next week
and both ruto and ryla had said that
they would respect the decision uh of
the court uh we'll probably hear from
them both in the coming hours but yeah
it was
nearly four weeks ago that kenyans voted
about three weeks ago that that result
was announced the electoral commission
announced william reuters the winner by
a narrow margin
and in two weeks ago that ryder redinger
came here submitted a petition it was
one of several petitions submitted here
at the court by
rights groups and the legal process has
gone on over the last two weeks we've
just had that ruling now
and the court has said it's not ordering
a rerun of the election
and that it is upholding
the result as you say malcolm both raila
odinga and william roto had said they
would accept the decision of the supreme
court the question now is of course
whether their supporters especially
raila odinga supporters will also
accept this decision
that's true but uh the supporters uh
definitely will uh it depends a lot on
what the leaders uh say uh so if uh
political leaders continue to uh to
respect the jurisdiction and the
judgment of of the court uh then we
could expect calm
things are quite different to how they
were 15 years ago when uh
in the violence following that election
more than a thousand people were killed
hundreds of thousands of people were
displaced uh from their homes but this
followed
election campaigns during which uh
ethnicity was uh used as a as a
campaigning tool uh the violence was uh
according to international criminal
court deliberately incited
by politicians the campaigns didn't
really sound like that this time
there isn't any sign of seeing repeat
of that kind of violence but of course
we'll be waiting to see how people react
later today and staying across that
thank you very much malcolm for the
moment malcolm webb live in nairobi
where again the kenyan supreme court has
has upheld the election a victory of
william ruto as president in a unanimous
decision after rejecting the claims of
ruto's opponent raila odinga will have
more reaction and analysis on al jazeera
throughout the day here on the story